hi guys scifi recapped here
before we start warning
spoilers ahead today i'm gonna explain a
2022 korean science fiction action movie
called alienoid
the movie begins with an evil alien race
known as para who is imprisoned on earth
they are trapped within humans brains
and become unaware of themselves
however sometimes they become self-aware
and attempt to escape from their human
hosts that is why two good aliens guard
and thunder are tasked with dealing with
the escapees once upon a time in 14th
century earth a parrot in a woman's body
escapes leaving her badly injured guard
and thunder come through a
time-traveling portal chase the paro and
contain it in her last breaths the woman
asks guard to look after her baby he is
reluctant at first as his principal is
to never interfere with human business
but thunder who can shapeshift into
guard with various personalities seems
eager to adopt her
they leave the scene and travel back to
the year 2012. in their home gard puts
the paro in containment which hosts
seven other peros who previously escaped
through time and space
guard then finds the human baby in his
car's backseat brought by thunder
thunder proposes that they adopt her so
they can study her brain and better
understand the human species
back in 1391 a dosa or magician called
muruk makes a living by being a bounty
hunter
he owns an enchanted fan that can
control the wind and produces two
shape-shifting creatures and some
weapons the creatures take the shape of
cats but muruk can transform them into
humans that serve him after collecting
rewards for capturing three thieves he
plans to search for a mysterious blade
called the divine blade which offers a
big reward
he goes to dog turd his father who is in
prison who tells him that it was found
some time ago in a river it has a
strange diamond carved into it which
cannot be separated it accidentally flew
into a man and stabbed him but instead
of dying he became stronger the blade
was then owned by an ex-magistrate who
runs a bar named bayao nanjung in jiu
zion
miruk thanks his father by freeing him
from prison then leaves
muruk and his two servants then ask for
directions to bayan anjong
along the way they encounter suitor a
mysterious man wearing a modern suit
indicating he is not from that era
arriving at bayao nanjung the
ex-magistrate is not impressed with
muruk and refuses to serve him even
paralyzing him he then goes to receive a
guest which turns out to be suitor he
claims to know the origin of the blade
currently in the ex-magistrate's
possession actually he is a paro and
wants to claim the blade for himself
fatally injuring the ex-magistrate and
other people in the process the blade
falls off and is taken by dog turd who
is also after the blade a chase ensues
between dog turd suitor and muruk suitor
easily defeats the other two but the
blade is lost after recovering from
being beaten muric observes an alien
spaceship on the river
meanwhile in 2022 the baby that guard
and thunder adopted now a ten-year-old
girl named yin causes trouble at school
by running to the police station and
claiming that she is abducted by her
father she admits that she remembered
being abducted her father has been
messing with her mind and he has a droid
assistant named thunder but he does not
provide elaboration and waits for yin to
finish her classes he is greeted by an
aunt of yeon's friend who is clearly
attracted to him but he only reacts
coldly yet exits the school building and
they drive home
unbeknownst to guard she hides an old
phone on the car seat so she can collect
further proof that guard is talking to
thunder or doing secret alien stuff
behind her after she leaves the car she
overhears guard and thunder begin
talking about implantation in 18 hours
in the evening when guard is away yin
goes back to the car to take her phone
however the car automatically forbids
her from touching a suspicious equipment
box causing thunder to expose himself
thunder warmly welcomes her and explains
his and guards origins he also realizes
that ian has learned about the
implantation mission and tells her to
forget it before yeon can ask any more
questions thunder urges her to get out
of the car because guard is coming
outside of the car yeon can still hear
thunder telling guard that the
implantation will happen tomorrow at
jizen hospital
the next day yian makes her way to the
hospital
she encounters moon doo sock a police
detective
then a strange cloud appears in the sky
catching everyone's attention
the cloud conceals an alien ship that
ejects a black crystal to the hospital
the crystal emits a black substance
piercing through everyone's body
including moondu socks yin attempts to
escape then she locks eyes with guard
guard is confused to meet yin but she
quickly runs away
after getting corrupted with the black
substance the humans continue their day
as if nothing happened
back to the past two mages from
samgokson huxseal and chong-woon aim to
sell magical antiques to zhang the
leader of the milbone temple
zhang does not seem impressed with the
items they offer but when he learns that
the mages know about the divine blade he
wants to work with them to find the
blade meanwhile muruk finds suitor's
crib finding images of aliens in the
divine blade the mysterious blade they
are all looking for
muric disguises himself as a groom on
his way to marry his bride believing the
blade is hidden somewhere between the
wedding gifts he discovers his bride has
a modern pistol indicating she is from
the future she offers him a drink which
he accepts but then he quickly runs to
the storage room to look for the blade
jang and the samgok mages then arrive
and siege the house also looking for the
blade
muric suddenly becomes weak realizing he
has been poisoned by the bride who is
also a pretender
meanwhile she prepares to claim the
blade and face jang and the mages but
she is defeated and is taken hostage in
the milbon temple muruk secretly
retrieves the bride's pistol before she
is taken away
back in 2022 yeon runs away from home to
her friend
garda signs thunder to bring ian home
at home ye and demands her questions
about them be answered guard and thunder
then explained to her that they
imprisoned paro in humans minds with the
hopes that if the human dies the paro
dies too if aparra escapes their job is
to deal with it they never interfere in
human matters except for adopting yin
because if she is left behind she would
have died as a baby
moon doo sock acts weird during his work
becoming more violent
the paro prisoner inside him is taking
control and wants to break free a paro
ship arrives on earth on a mission to
release moon du sac from his paro
guard and thunder quickly leave to find
moon doo sock and intercept the paro
while yin insists to tag along with them
a chase ensues between moon doo sock the
paro and guard turns out the prisoner
inside moon doo sock is called
controller a powerful paro he can be
released if moon doo sock is stabbed by
the divine blade after successfully
completing his mission the paro
detonates himself fatally injuring guard
thunder rushes to give guard more life
support but guard decides to continue
chasing after controller they sneak into
controller's spaceship learning that he
plans to release java bubbles that
change the earth's atmosphere to be
suitable for them to exist without human
hosts but unhabitable for humans
their fight causes two hava bubbles to
break out so they try their best to keep
them from spreading
however a bubble already bursts and
causes many people to lose their breath
yin is fortunately saved by thunder who
sends guard's car to drive her home
the mysterious gun wielding bride turns
out to be grown up yin now trapped in
the past looking for controller
suitor and zhang the paro who are also
trapped in the past are also looking for
controller who they believe has changed
his host to a different human from mundu
sock
that is why they were after the blade
and attempted to stab many people with
it
meanwhile muruk and his men disguise
themselves to get into the melbourne
temple the divine blade suddenly glows
on its own surprising everyone in the
room
muruk is then tasked to deliver dinner
for yin
he shows her pistol and throws it at her
yin convinces muric that she came from
the future but he tells her that he
believes they have met sometime in the
past
hearing the footsteps of other guards
niruk leaves
after retrieving the gun yeon falls
unconscious
the mages are having dinner but quickly
realize that the food is poisoned
they become paralyzed and not aware that
muruk is stealing the divine blade
behind their backs however muruk soon
realizes that if the mage's food is
poisoned yinz was poisoned too and
quickly leaves to save her with an
elixir from the mages he gives her the
elixir but zhang and his men surround
them and kill them both
they are then put inside coffins to be
buried and drowned
back in 2022 garth is determined to set
yin free so she is far from harm's way
while he finishes his mission to find
controller and stop the hava spread
thunder drives ye in a way but he
realizes ye and truly wants to help
guard and that it might increase their
chance of success so they come back to
help guard they chase after zhang suitor
and controller to reclaim the divine
blade and defeat them
realizing that they have nowhere to run
and to keep the paro away from their
spaceship guard opens the time
travelling portal to the 14th century
sending all of them to the past
turns out the mages and muruk who was
still a little kid saw the portal open
the fight between guard thunder and yin
against the paro continues
guard fights controller until his limb
breaks and disintegrates then yin shoots
controller with a pistol she hides in
her backpack
now that his host's body is badly
damaged controller needs to find a new
host to ensure his survival
meanwhile yin falls to the river along
with a blade
she swims to the surface and is found by
muruk who helps her search for the blade
mirror could not find it but he was able
to retrieve her backpack
the older muru can ye and then realize
that they have met before then regain
their consciousness and escape from
their coffins yin shoots her way out of
the coffin and searches the temple to
retrieve the blade while facing zhang
and suitor the mages help her to fight
against the paro using their antique
magical items
huxseal uses a magical magnifying mirror
to magnify her hands and yin's bullets
to effectively attack the paro
yeon runs with the blade with jang and
his paro chasing after her
she abandons her boat and quietly
crosses the river by swimming
meanwhile muruk successfully summons a
sword from his enchanted fan to fight
against the paro he kills suitor in his
paro which before he dies tells muruk
that he has something special within him
turns out that after little muruk helped
little yin out of the river they made a
fire and heard a strange sound
when muruk wandered to check the sound
controller still inside moon doo sock
appeared he transferred himself to
muric's body making him the new host
the mages realize that muruk is the
controller that the other paro have been
looking for and are questioning whether
they must kill him or not
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching